What is the next story, Ross?
All right, well, this is exciting movie news,
we have our first trailer for "Scream 5."
Now, who was in the first scream?
Oh, that's right, you.
You were, Drew Barrymore.
(audience applauding)
Guilty as charged.
And "Scream 5" is coming soon.
We've got a first look.
Whatever his link is to our past,
it's pulled us all back here.
(siren wailing)
(dramatic music)
And I won't sleep until he's in the ground.
(audience applauding)
Now "Scream 5" doesn't come out until January 14th,
but they say it's gonna be worth the wait.
The original cast is back, except for you.
(audience laughing)
Well, 'cause, if you haven't seen it, spoiler alert,
she dies.
(audience laughing)
I don't watch that many scary movies,
but I'm gonna go to this one,
because I just watched the first one because you're in it.
And you're really good in it, by the way.
Thank you.
Really!
Really good!
(audience applauding)
I took it as such an acting challenge.
I read Kevin Williamson's script and I was...
It was called "Scary Movie" at the time, not "Scream."
Which ended up ironically being the parody's name.
And I just thought,
god, you know what sucks about scary movies is
you always know that main person's gonna make it,
like, by the skin of their teeth.
What if we took that out?
I die and all bets are off.
And then it just took off into this wonderful genre
of a horror film.
It was funny, it was irreverent, it was interesting.
And this is the first time I've been like, damn,
I wish I wasn't dead, I want to be in this movie.
(audience laughing)
I love the way that they've actually made it
genuinely scary.
And I think it's gonna be a big deal, I do.
I remember after seeing that movie,
when I go home at night, that it is the reason
that I do not linger in the downstairs area.
That I go straight to my bedroom and I shut the door,
because if there's anyone around,
I just want to sleep through it, you know what I mean?
Yes!
If there's an intruder or an attacker,
I want to be out cold when that happens.
Yeah.
I don't want to fight.
I don't want to chase anybody around my house with a knife,
or anything like that.
No, I'm good.
Yeah!
I was also upset that the popcorn got burnt.
That really bugged me.
(Drew laughing)
You let it burn.
I want to talk to you about that.
Are you a fan of scary movies?
I don't, no.
I mean, that I watched also 'cause Drew was in it,
but I don't like scary movies.
I don't like violence.
I don't mind being scared, but I don't like gory violence.
No, no.
You know?
I'm not down with that.
I like "Steel Magnolias."
That's like it for me in terms of...
The scene with orange juice, that freaked me out.
No more!
Nothing past that.
That's "Steel Magnolias"?
"Drink your juice, Shelby.
"Don't talk about me like I'm not here."
Remember?
Okay, Chelsea, it's your next story?
Okay, I'm gonna do a news story.
It has been two years since the horror of "Cats" the movie.
(Ross laughing)
(audience applauding)
And Andrew Lloyd Webber is still traumatized
by what Hollywood did to his musical.
So "People" is reporting the famous Broadway composer
recently revealed he had to get an emotional support animal
after seeing the movie "Cats."
Andrew said, when he saw the movie,
all he thought was, oh god, no!
(audience laughing)
Well, that's a very special review.
You know "Cats" had to be that bad
if someone this gay refused to see it, you know?
(audience laughing)
The reviews were so unbelievable.
Did you see it?
I did not see it.
I heard about it.
I'm not really into "Cats" to begin with,
so it wasn't really hard for me not to see that movie,
but I heard how horrible it was.
What was so bad about it?
You know what, I wish now that I would've seen it,
so I could talk to you about how truly bad it was.
Who was in it?
Do we know who was in it?
I can run that down.
Taylor Swift was in it, Jennifer Hudson was in it,
Dame Judi Dench was in it.
You'd think it'd be good, right?
(audience laughing)
Yeah, what's she doing in a bad movie, Dame Judi Dench?
She's never been in anything bad.
No.
But now she has.
Yeah.
Also, why were people so mad about it?
Did everyone hold "Cats" that dearly?
Like, what is the deal?
I think "Cats" was a lot of people's
very first Broadway experience.
And I think that 'cause
I know it was my first Broadway play.
Mine too!
So it was "Barnum and Bailey" and then "Cats."
I never saw "Cats" 'cause I had...
This is such a deep dive into my childhood,
but my neighbor had a cat that was really mean,
so cats have always scared me.
So I never wanted to see the musical
'cause I thought it would bring back childhood trauma.
But "Cats" aren't that friendly, though.
I mean, they have that reputation for a reason.
(Drew laughing)
There's no warm fuzzies going on.
(audience applauding)
I've never had one.
Yeah, well, anyway.
So, Chelsea, you know you love
to stir things up on the internet.
So Chelsea put out these debates on Instagram and online,
it was do you do your toilet paper under or over.
Uh huh!
Raise of hands who's an over.
Yeah.
Raise your hands if you're an under.
Okay, we are animals apparently.
And then show this towel picture,
'cause I participated in this too.
And the biggest movie stars on the planet
participated in this.
Raise your hand if you're a one.
Raise your hand if you're a two.
Okay.
And three.
Oh, okay, three looks like you're living in a spa.
(audience laughing)
Right!
Congrats on your life if you're a three.
Literally, what is wrong with me?
I am an under and a sad folder.
What's wrong with me?
I didn't know that I was off, like weird.
I know, I don't think a lot of people knew
until it was put in front of them,
and then people went nuts about it.
So, yeah, it's very divisive.
Yes, it is.
I mean you had the biggest stars in Hollywood
chiming in about how they're an over or an under,
or a towel folder.
Anyway, when it's over, I feel like it just never ends
and you waste toilet paper.
Under puts a stopgap on there.
Well, what sparked the conversation is,
you know in airports, the toilet paper,
how you grab a piece and it stops.
One piece!
And it rips it off.
That makes me upset, because no one needs just one piece.
No!
You know?
A piece, even like a thing.
I feel like it's just a pinch.
And you have to pull it.
And you're like, that puts us all
in a bad situation, right?
'Cause you wanna leave the restroom nice
for the next person who comes along, obviously.
So they should be allowing us to get some more toilet paper.
So that's the first thing that they need to fix
is the airports.
You should run for office.
I'm just saying.
You just earned my vote.
Thank you.
But, maybe!
Hold on, I think we might've found another debate.
Here's a question I have.
If you see the roll is empty at someone's house
or in a public space, do you change it?
Always!
Me too!
That's common courtesy.
Who else?
Anybody?
Yeah.
And who's not raising their hands, and why?
(audience laughing)
Interesting.
Let's all work together, okay?
Thank you!
I agree completely.
(upbeat music)